I don't think actors know diddly squat
about communication I really don't I
think that actors are terrible
communicators as people by and large I
think our tendency is to kind of be
self-centered and and tune people out
and and just kind of get really me
focused so I think communication for
actors is a big challenge actually I'll
tell you I'm a much better listener when
I'm acting than I am as a person in real
life because you learn as an actor that
listening is so important we have to
really key in to what the other person
you're acting with is saying and how
they're saying it and react in the
moment to what's going on I'm much more
in the moment when I'm acting I can be
in my life I'm just like and then I'm
acting I'm like boom you know just zero
in and clock in and I've noticed that
about a lot of actors a lot of actors
are just like they're never really
connected and then they're in the scene
and then BOOM and looking you in the
eyes and they're just really focused